pour en parler nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec jean sébastien ferjou
fondateur d'atlantico directeur de la
publication même temps soir sébastien
jean sébastien ferjou merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france adore un
mot déjà sur cette contestation qui
reprend de plus belle en france est-ce
qu'elle va servir à quelque chose selon
vous elle va servir à quelque chose en
tout cas pas pour empêcher la procédure
du 49-3 ni le fait que le projet de loi
puisse être en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale a adopté après la
problématique politique reste entière
pour le gouvernement c'est à dire que ce
qui est un peu perturbant c'est pas leur
courant soit au 49 3 votre reportage le
rappeler c'est loin d'être la première
fois qu'un gouvernement recourt à cet
article de la constitution en revanche
c'est le contexte
et là on voit bien qu'il ya un problème
de calendrier et non seulement bien
point de calendrier mais peut-être moins
de maîtrise de la part du gouvernement
puisque si le gouvernement en gros il ya
les élections municipales le
gouvernement souhaitait avoir fini avant
en tout cas la phase de l'assemblée
nationale avant
le premier tour des municipales ce qui
l'a contraint à s'engager dans une
procession une procédure accélérée et
c'est ce qui lui a fait qu'il ne peut
pas bénéficier de la procédure de temps
de temps programmé parlementaire donc le
gouvernement s'est lui même mis dans la
masse dans la nasse juridique on voit
bien que le sujet peut-être plus que
d'empêcher la reprise du mouvement c'est
d'empêcher ou de mettre un terme aux
débats qui commençait à se faire jour au
sein de sa propre majorité
si les élections municipales il ya
beaucoup de candidats qui sont enfin
deux candidats qui portent les couleurs
de la république en marche sur le
terrain qui se heurte à une forme
d'hostilité de la population et donc
c'est compliqué quand on est candidat
aux municipales à la fois de devoir
défendre nationalement le projet de loi
sur la réforme des retraites tout en se
montrant plus dubitatif dans les faits
pour éviter le suicide électoral
cette stratégie pour vous allez
finalement c'est méline la part du
gouvernement où elle est totalement
suicidaire voire inconsciente suicidaire
je ne sais pas mais manny non jetable
électoralement parlant je pense qu'il ya
vraiment une forme d'amateurisme il
vraiment une femme et josé sur la
technique même
parlementaire un manque de maîtrise
quant au sens politique par philippe a
pu faire la preuve dans le passé qui
n'en avaient pas forcément des quantités
industrielles à revendre enfin séduit
qui n'a pas vu venir la crise ou en tout
cas ce que les protestations qu'elle ait
généré des 80 km heure sur la taxe
carbone c'était la même chose sur un
certain nombre de choses comme ça je
même sur le congé parental vous savez
quand les députés quand on a reproché
aux députés d'avoir voté contre un
amendement proposant d'allonger le congé
de deuil pour des parents qu aurait
perdu un enfant c'était quand même
remonter à matignon et matignon il n'y a
pas vu de problème je pense que le
calcul politique est assez hasardeux et
que rien n'est réglé parce que l'enjeu
politique reste le même
effectivement c'est quand même une des
formes qui met la majorité du pays
contre le gouvernement les sondages le
disent les français on à jour était
nouvelle passe de cette réforme la bulle
et les avocats dans la rue c'est assez
rare on peut se demander comment un
gouvernement espère effectivement gagné
les municipales et peut-être d'autres
élections après en passant en force
comme ça je serais si gouvernement
espère encore gagner
les municipales puisque de toute façon
ce sont des élections compliquées pour
la république en marche qui a peu
d'ancrage peu d'ancrage territorial en
revanche il ya un enjeu politique majeur
pour le gouvernement et pour emmanuel
macron en particulier dans la
perspective d'une éventuelle candidature
en 2022 qui est de dire regardez ce que
d'autres n'ont pas su faire avant moi
j'ai réussi à le faire et dans un pays
conduit réformable j'ai réussi à mener à
bien une réforme que beaucoup avaient
voulu entreprendre auparavant à savoir
en soit la réforme des retraites
d'ailleurs mais de mettre un terme aux
régimes spéciaux et maintenant moi je
vois trois questions politiques qui se
pose pour les gouvernements qui dans ce
pays est capable de dire si cette
réforme est juste ou non et si le
système produit sera plus juste que le
système précédent parce que c'est une
chose de vouloir marquer des points sur
la réforme mais les gens sont pas non
plus totalement aveugle ils peuvent se
poser des questions sur l'intérêt de la
réforme qui qui seraient passés donc est
ce que cette réforme va être juste 2 2
est-ce que elle garantit mieux que le
système actuel la pérennité du système
de retraite français même chose je suis
pas certain qu'il soit possible d'y
apporter une réponse en état et de 3,7
réforme est-elle maîtrisé et on le voit
les études d'impact personne n'est
capable véritablement de faire des
études d'impact dans le trou ça fait
quand même beaucoup d'inconnues et que
se lancer dans une réforme systémique
à la limite même si on est en faveur
d'une réforme d'un passage à un système
par points s'est lancé dans une réforme
systémique quand on a une minorité
sociologique dans le pays même si la
légalité et légitimité incontestable à
la majorité en marche
enfin y'a pas une adhésion
majeur à sa vision et sa vision du monde
se lancer dans une réforme de cette
ampleur là ça me paraît très très casse
cou politiquement et loire philippe qui
tente de rassurer le nouveau texte est
enrichi de tous les acquis de la
négociation avec les partenaires sociaux
et les amendements déposés sains par la
majorité
selon lui ce qu'on peut bien le croire
alors que vous le soulignez on a du mal
à connaître les tenants et aboutissants
de cette réforme
je pense qu'il ya des sujets qui sont
quand même paru d'un parce qu'ils
étaient apparus malgré tout pendant les
deux ans de concertation ou alors parce
qu'ils sont portés par les uns et les
autres soient des députés de la majorité
soit des partenaires sociaux ayant
plutôt envie de travailler avec le
gouvernement pour que cette réforme ne
passe donc le gouvernement fait des
efforts incontestablement il ya des
choses qui ont été inclus donc ils
seront inclus dans le va être soumis
justement au vote par le 49-3 il ya des
efforts qui ont été faits est maintenant
derrière il ya quand même le sénat et la
majorité républicaine au sénat ne va pas
faire de cadeau au gouvernement puisque
le président du sénat gérard larcher a
demandé un report de 15 jours en disant
ça n'a pas beaucoup de chance de nous
demander d'examiner le projet de loi
alors qu'on ne sait pas quelles seront
les conclusions de la conférence de
financement donc c'est à la fois très
très défendable sur le sur le fond d'un
point de vue rationnel et il ya aussi
une habileté à le faire de cette manière
là parce que la réalité c'est que
vraisemblablement il n'y aura pas de
compromis trouvé dans la conférence de
fiances de financement merci beaucoup en
tout cas jean sébastien ferjou fondateur
d'été d'atlantico d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france est restée